with the government losing this vote
we're back deep into the brexit
labyrinth and the next turn is crucial
as to where we end up so what are the
options first Labour tabled a
no-confidence vote in the government
Jeremy Corbyn will make his pitch for
labour to seize power and control of the
negotiations his problem is he's
unlikely to get the required number of
votes in Parliament it's really
important in relations so we can finally
speak in vote out this shall have a
Labour government with Jeremy Corbyn as
Prime Minister from what I've been
hearing from the conservative group of
ERG MPs and for I've been hearing from
the DP appears unlikely much to my
disappointment that the inner confidence
motion will succeed in defeat the prime
minister said the public deserves
clarity party hopes that what looks like
a dead end can become a New Deal the EU
said it can't be done but to resume has
little choice but to try to renegotiate
the withdrawal agree and many Tory MPs
will accept nothing less than scrapping
the controversial back stock the
Commission now Germany wants to get back
into negotiations again so all this
stuff about them not negotiating I'm
afraid will go she goes back they
negotiate hard they get a better
arrangement than the one they've got and
then they come back and if they get a
good set of changes then I think there's
every chance that this will go through
but if the government can't work it out
and the opposition can't get into
government where then could MPs be
allowed to table their own motions in a
new system where Parliament takes
control it would be a revolutionary
change there is an argument that if you
want to chart your way through this
parliamentary puzzle then why not let
the MPs do it themselves they may for
example find that there's a majority
support for the Norway model staying in
the single market but allowing free
movement of people however MPs would be
wary of choosing this softer brexit
without a new mandate from the people so
is a second referendum the
only way to settle this going back to
the people will be necessary there's not
going to be a consensus in here for
anything I don't believe I happen to
think it's the right thing to do this is
such a momentous choice for our country
there's currently no majority in
parliament for people's vote it would
require extending article 50 delaying
brexit and would lead to a whole new set
of dilemmas but if no solution is found
no deal becomes the default option if we
prepare properly we can keep any
disruption to a minimum and I would hope
that would also be a path to the
comprehensive Canada Star free trade
agreement which ultimately I hope is is
what we achieve no deal comes with
warnings of tariffs damage to industry
and price rises for consumers some
brexit ears see it as a clean break but
it's by no means an easy way out
Jason Farrell Sky News